hello everyone
came out we want to introduce the
general and portuguese and spanish station
we have the pleasure of offering this session
with three presentations by specialists from
latin america make up how it had been
used by the laboratories to
solve the purchasing crisis
representing carolina brazil
for the three points
[Music]
and
is a Spanish language
welcome to all my name is Manuel
Escalera I am eternal official and together with
Rafael I am and we will pursue this
regional reform session in Portuguese and Spanish
we are very happy the
expression appears with three presentations by
experts focused on how DNA  it is
used is used by laboratories
to solve crime that
always comes up don benito from
doctor erika from mexico who will soon
start the presentation at the end of
each session there will be an opportunity
for each speaker to answer some of
your questions
so make sure  to send them in the
resales box and answer  As a
reminder this session offers
free continuing education projects you
can look at the
continuing education credits tab located
in the upper right corner
of the presentation window and you can
follow the process to get your
full geography credits from us
visit the tab  at the top
of the screen and well let's start with
the presentations first room given by
america then doctor
benito will present and then doctor carolina the
doctor dedicates this computer to the
forensic chemistry and genetics laboratories
of the forensic intelligence laboratory of the prosecutor's office
general of state justice that new one go
ahead dedicate when you want to start
thank you very much every day
initially well thank you all very much
for this invitation and especially a
thank you to fermín alejandra the
whole team is to legislate for doing this
project not
the topic that I am going to present  may be
the obtaining  on genetic profiles
from biological evidence such as
fingerprints
in the day to day of our work with
criminal investigation we have
worked on the sound state channel we
have tried to work together on
multidisciplinary activities
depending on the investigation into the
crime that is being carried out  finds for those tried
to find that question or give
guidelines to that principle of exchange
that occurs in all criminal matters where
there is a relationship between the evidence, the
victim and the place of the facts thanks
to the improvement that has existed in
the techniques for the  DNA analysis
This allows us to carry out
these identifications and to be able to work
with the public prosecutor
to link those probable perpetrators in the
commission of the crimes,
first of all, the team that
enters the place of intervention or that
has contact with these indications
biological products, the use
of biosafety equipment is always important  d and before
entering that place of intervention,
they are duly protected,
protecting their people and protecting
that is biological evidence that is not
going to be altered that is not going to be
contaminated, taking into account the measures of
the security protocol, using
clothing, the appropriate material for
the  Collection and packaging where we
completely protect it is an indication
that it will not be altered in its use.
Compensation when the
laboratory work begins, when the
criminal expert, the place of intervention,
leads to those indications or those objects that
may have biological evidence such
as  fingerprints and are
transported to the crime laboratory located
on the campus together
with the scottish is the
criminal expert the chemical expert assess
each of these objects to
search for locations
both biological and physical evidence
work together for the analysis of these of
these objects
Giving importance to the evidence
both physical and biological, for example,
if they have a firearm and in the
thin or small parts of this
object where it is impossible for a
fragment of the trace to remain in its
entirety, because that surface is valued
there and the chemist proceeds
to collect it  Subsequently,
the sample or object is subjected to various
chemical processes and for the development of
these fingerprints in
the search and location stage,
a variety of reagents can be applied,
among the most common being
black powder or black oxide.
magnetic poles the fluorescent towns the
ni godmother the purple and Christian in
these in this application of reagents it
is important for the development of these
traces on the surfaces of these
objects but it is also important for
genetic analysis if the web has its
characteristic contour for  make an
identification
through the afis system in the in the
in the study of this footprint because
genetics values ​​and  sa of that sample and
analyze it to obtain its genetic profile
, these disciplines work together
and value the objects
first if there is no suitable surface
for a footprint to be characteristic
or for its identification characteristic to be revealed,
then it is submitted to
collection by  through a swab with
saline solution after
all the chemical reagents are applied, because on the
surfaces where the tracks do not have
the contour or the ridges and the
ideal characteristics, it is
also collected with this equipment, but if
the buoys and have their characteristic  Well,
first the print is lifted according
to the techniques used by each
area. The most common is the tape and they
place it on its contrast support, but
on that surface where the
print is collected, the
swab is lifted to
destroy the contour of the print.  water and to the
surface where it was is is
adhered that is where the collection is done
at the same time as they are lifted  After
these indications are placed on
a support to subsequently
stain and after these indications
are placed in their appropriate packaging
and following the chain of custody protocols,
they are packaged,
labeled and recorded
once these reagents  are
used to go through a
decontamination process using
the n asã reagent to
decontaminate any DNA that may
have adhered to the particles
of the reagent and then go through an
irradiation with ultraviolet light
to eliminate everything that has
remained when applying  this reagent
with an ultra violet, sorry, well,
the sample was
submitted to that support for the search
for cells, it passes the chemistry laboratory,
specifically in geology, and the
search for cells is done through a
methylene stain, the cells
are so noble  that are stained with
any dye, then we
use blue of  methylene because it is a
quick and easy technique, once
these cells are obtained, which have the presence of
cells from these beginnings that were
collected, then they pass to the flow in the
genetics laboratory, it is worth mentioning
that in the genetics laboratory the
entire process, all the flow that is done  In
the analysis of these indications it is
more completely automated.
Most of the equipment is from UPL. There are
several ists where we carry out the
entire flow to obtain profiles.
The genetics laboratory is now making
identification of each having
paternity tests.  You compare
evidence against probables and victims and
we also have a good database that
returns to the flow once the
samples are in the
genetics laboratory once they have been
registered and assigned the number
that individualizes each one of them.  these
samples and pass to the process fragments
the amount of sample we need
for the next step which is the
ex  traction in the extraction part or
in the extraction stage we
use the automated equipment of
auto mes de playboy or system and we submit
to the chemistry of the reagents with the
file air express when the samples
are in the swab and profiler express
better when  those samples of the
prints that were revealed because they
are on the tapes with gumming that
were revealed with a
gentian violet or that are found on the
support with the tape because they are already submitted
to the pre file air express
dt
a process once we obtain  our that
we have our DNA extract passes is
the next stage which is the pre psr and
here the sample is conditioned in
the plate with its reagent and the sample in
the automated process we
use the
hamilton block nimbus robot and  in this robot, it
normalizes all the silver, captures,
conditions the sample with its reagent and
proceeds to the quantification in which the psr
in real
time quantifies
Once we
have the ideal amount established
in our validation process and that
the sample is in optimal amounts
to do this amplification, we go to the
next to the next stage the flow
returns  to the ppc r it is
conditioned again in the plate in the same one that
has the same robot
but now it is for the
amplification process using the
global filer reagents in the
amplification process we use the
thermal cyclers to see it and when it is the
plate  complete and profs when they are
portions or with samples that are not the
entire amplification plate
once we obtain
our applied ours then we move on to the
specification of the str fragments
by means of capillary electrophoresis
using the apply maya 3500 equipment
system
once obtained these results that
are interpreted with imma pérez and
analyze them the re  The results of
each of the samples in this part, well,
I am going to project the profiles
that we have obtained, we also obtain
good, within the profiles that
are obtained, mixtures of more than three individuals are obtained,
but in the laboratory
we do not interpret this
amount of  individuals, the maximums are
mixtures of the individuals and iu of a
single contributor, since in the image that
is being projected the one on the
left side is behind the wheel of a vehicle
on this surface, a sample is collected
directly from this surface
and the entire  flow of the
genetics laboratory and it is obtained
in this particular case because it is a
genetic profile with
a mixture of two male individuals
and on its right side there
is a profile of an individual of
a male person, a single
individual but this  was from a
fingerprint that was collected using or
applying the powder reagent or
black oxide the conduit is used p  For
the disclosure of the fingerprints
in the following we have some
and also unique profiles of people
of the male sex and one of them, as
on his left side is a
trace of a surface that was
revealed with magnetic powder and the one on his
right side  I'm going to throw that away too
but this one was revealed with
essential violet the one with violet and
gentian was on a
gummed support on a rubberized tape and its
extraction process was to go to
all the previous ones they were to prefer
stress
these are the results  that we have
obtained and given to those to those commissions
or those results that we have or we help
with the public ministry so that it
is in a position to be able to link
a person not in the investigation and to be
able to link it to a
process below I am going to present a case
so quickly from one of those that
have given us the most and in particular this is
the one that
is not caused the most satisfaction by obtaining
results  It is a case of a homicide
where a person is deprived of his life
in a place in a place where the events took place,
so the colleagues come to
do the collection, they do not do the
processing at the scene and this case
is linked through evidence of  the
genetic profiles obtained both in
that place of intervention and in all
the places of investigation
carried out by the police officers of the
investigation police carried out several
places of investigation and it is the way
in which the link is made in this case
because in the place of  intervention
the experts collect an object that was
left in that place at the time of the
commission of the crime and it is
obtained the collection of the samples
the development of the prints that were not
as the eligible prints were and is
submitted in the process of  dna then in
this process in the samples
a mixture of two individuals called
male 1 and 2 is obtained then a link is made
to the days to the various days  via
a search process and obtained
from the objects that are produced in that
place, unique profiles of
three individuals called masculine 1
2 and 3 are obtained, the masculine together are those who
are present in the mixture of the place
of intervention, in addition to a trace in
lifted from a surface in that
research house or in that
research place that print was complete
and it was possible to obtain the identification of
a person with all their
general data that are established in the
tenprint file and that print
corresponds to the individual named
male 1 in addition  in a vehicle that
was in the place, it is also read in
the search place, samples are collected
and a mixture of two individuals is obtained
that also correspond to
individual 1 and 2 and finally in a
firearm in that search place
the profile is found to be a mixture
of masculine one with masculine 3
but in addition to
the firing firearm it was
determined  for the apartment and ballistics
that was used at
the scene so in this way is
how through genetics we can
link from the place of intervention
and in all the objects that were used
to commit this crime
The dactyloscopy disciplines of
criminalistics were carried out by means
of identification of an individual's afis and
ballistics with the tool to determine
that a weapon was used and how
genetics was linked from the place
in all the objects that were found
in that investigation, allowing the
public prosecutor's office  that it will request an
arrest warrant against that
individual and then the connection
with all the investigations, such as
the connection of that individual with
the commission of that crime
in a very quick way, since this is the
work that we have presented and
what we have found throughout
these investigations thank you very much
thank you erika let's go with a  Question that
the question was sent
and how do you coordinate with the
fingerprint development laboratory to define
who has priority since the fingerprint
will be destroyed in a smooth pair for DNA,
first of all working together
when they are doing the search and
location of these fingerprints  So
if the surface is not suitable for a
fingerprint that in its entire
contour, then right there they decide that
the chemist lifts the sample on that
surface, respecting the entire contour
of that object after applying the
reagents for revealing the fingerprints and
If the print does not have the outline, it does not
have the characteristic reliefs,
then it is collected with the swab, but
if the print does have 6, if it has those
particular characteristics that the
cloth shows, then it is collected with the
techniques applied by each
department, they collect that print.  and
later on the support where that
footprint was, there is a lifting with the
swab on that s  critical surface
no questions have been sent
thank you very much applied in yum
and now let's move on to doctor
benito he is coordinator of
scientific research at the
criminalistics and expert services institute of
the state attorney general's office
of new leon go ahead benito
when you want to start
answers  Thank you very much for the
invitation, thank you for the opportunity to
share this with you.
I am going to start the presentation. First,
I will put them in a context of our
unit. I belong to the
Scientific Research Coordination of the
Attorney General's Office of the State
of Nuevo León,
to put them.  in locating them in the context
where we hired ourselves located because
we are in the north of Mexico in the northeast,
specifically the border with the USA and
we are a state that has an average of
4 and a half million inhabitants and
this requires a fairly
large structure for the expert investigation in
our  institute is an institute of  more
than 500 forensic experts from at least 34
disciplines, mainly
genetics and criminalistics, this semefo
among others is a fairly robust group
because unfortunately we say this is
due to the crime that has
existed in recent years but
we are also  a large group that,
thanks to the support of our
institutions in investigating and
contributing to this subject of
expert technical investigation, we
identified some critical points for
the subject of raising the evidence and
that these are effective during their
analysis in the laboratories, we know that
much of what  raised in the field area, it
will end up in the
genetics laboratories, so here it is important
that we have excellent professions,
follow-ups in field linguistics and
in the intermediate laboratories for the
analysis of evidence in order to sift
and that what reaches the units of
genetic analysis is really material
that we are going to have  r what is going to be
successful in the criminalization procedure,
on the other hand, the challenge also comes not
only in the expert investigation
but also in the
criminal investigation part, I believe that
one of the critical points here is the
question of time when not  there is when
a crime occurred depending on the
laws of the states or
countries, we know that we have
very little time to present
arguments or evidence to be able to link
to the process or simply present this
evidence once it has been analyzed
by laboratories in order to  to continue
with the investigation,
without a doubt, there is this joint work
between the investigator and prosecutor and
the expert services, the
scientific observers is decisive for the
success of the investigations, but
also without a doubt the methods of analysis
that they use, which are above all
fast and reliable methods, if we see  an example
these are data from the
criminal activity  From our state
of Nuevo León, the data is published
nationally and the
number of crimes that occur is worrying, and I am going to
cite only one of them, for example,
crimes against freedom and
sexual security are undoubtedly a
problem, we have more than  Of the 2,600 crimes that
occur annually, we are
thinking that at least
5 to 6,000 biological signs emerge that will
end up being analyzed in the
different laboratories of our
sbs institution, a high percentage
will reach the genetic laboratory and
an infrastructure is undoubtedly required.
large enough to be able to make a
precise analysis of all this
evidence
in knowledge of the flow that is
in the genetic laboratory we know that
a process of a preserved sample gives
a robust sample will allow us to
carry out a technification in an
average time of  12 hours but
additionally put another 12
hours in which a search is done in
databases in what is established to
the calculations in what form is made
its opinion forms to the prosecutor then an
average time would be 24 hours and there is a
natural evolution of the
genetic analysis systems and we have experienced that
in the  laboratories
so what can we see
because the equipment has allowed us to be
more robust analyzes a greater number of
samples processed we started with a
genetic alert three days we are
with 3,500 but also in the same way
there has been an evolution of the methods such
as  Former rapid extraction methods
psrs which consume the least time
in processing and on the other hand
rapid isolation techniques at this
point we have had the
opportunity to work with a
fast and capable system where we have
tested this technology for a flow
that  It was seen in a general way, it
is a laboratory with a
single piece of equipment in a single unit because you only need
to take the  The sample is processed
in the equipment in a short time, emits
the results, which you can quietly
and with the reduction in time,
enjoy a coffee while discussing
the results with your colleagues. In the end,
I think that this reduction in time is very
promising and would help us a lot.  in the
technical part because they would concentrate the
effort more in the interpretation of your
results than in the
technical processing but where would we apply it or
what would be the use of it
having a huge workload I
think that we have seen a
possibility especially in  the issue of
arrests, especially when they are
serious crimes in which an investigation can be carried
out at this level to
determine if these people who have
committed a crime may be
linked to other processes or to other
investigations by another party in
our work experience in
our region as we have seen we
have been affected by the issue of
organized crime and
catastrophes and we know that the
rapid response in genetic regulations and in
the results I think helps both
society and the proper functions of
our institutions and
particularly ours perhaps the prosecutor's office how
that very simple system works and I really
mean it  so because it is very simple what
happens in a cartridge and in a piece of equipment and in
the end in this in this part where
the determination can be made,
the analysis of the magisterial
amplification in a moment of crisis and
the detection and the results
can simply be  carried out
remotely from our institutions
[Applause]
when, as
we are doing now, there is
validation,
as we say, we implement it in
our working group, well, to
validate it, we established
evaluation criteria for contamination,
sensitivity, credibility and other
parameters, but mainly we
focus on  some important points
that is the sensibility  because we know
that the samples can be complex and
carried out by different people and there
we have the doubt if ours was
enough to be able to make an
accurate analysis one obtain a genetic profile
on the other hand we also tried other
illusions of blood particularly in
knowledge for example  Of the
autopsy cases where there is coagulation and the
blood samples
normally already have
low cell concentrations, which is what we found
in this whole process. Well, here
we had the opportunity to
identify some points that
we already knew were going to be critical.  For
example, when we talked about scraping
the buccal cheek scrub with a
single touch, we knew that there could be
a problem in the matter of
genetic profiling,
so in illusions,
if we see an example of the results,
for example, of a buccal cheek with a
single touch, well,  this came out of all
forecasts we thought it was not going
to come out  go to the genetic profile but
we were certainly surprised because
we were indeed able to obtain a clear genetic profile,
there are important points that we have
to clarify that in some markers
the distraction reflexes were
around 53 avg ph rd 49% very
close to the established quality controls
by this team that others
come out those were not even typified
but in general we are this could
not be identified with this with this
initial sampling the rest
of ours presented favorable results,
that is, a genetic profile could be obtained
but it was possible to have a
healthy  complete genetic profile of the
samples
to the case
not only now thorium and we also had the
opportunity to work with another
conduit punto campeche system that is
fast intel and this other is designed
with an illusion volume of less than 300
micro liters and a cycle greater than 30  two
cycles of amplification this is undoubtedly a
little more focused on the subject of the
samples sample  as complex or
saliva or blood samples that are complex and
that are not also considered forensically in the same
way and for this we made a
plan but we established a verification
due to the number of cartridges we
had and we tested those
forensic samples that are common in our
laboratories  and that they are problems,
so we work on the illusions of
blood that did not appear in the
previous validation with the ordinary procedure
and we ran them with this system and
indeed the results were
complete profiles;
on the other hand, we work on contact samples,
that is, the tongue or
mouthpiece of a  can the bottle a
plastic bottle tip
from a plastic drink bottle and
also in the same way the results
were favorable where we did not find
a favorable response it was in the
cotton mask machine or in the
latent print where we did not obtain a profile
or it was  a full profile the cigarette butts
the hair too  we have
for us to complete some cases that
also caught our attention were the
forensic cases that we had processed
with this previous system but that
have not given us a complete profile in one or
two markers we use the same and soho
processed in the previous procedure and
we process it by  this cartridge and
we surprise it was also that
we obtain a complete profile to
exemplify this I want to mention that
this system is designed to work
on my eyes not to work and
fragments of fabrics or fth what
we did was make a
technical adaptation simply to ensure that the
The fragment that we intended to analyze will be
found at the bottom of the cartridge,
ensuring that when
non-visual reagent substances are injected it will shoot
out and
the cartridge lid will be deposited. We made an
adaptation simply to be able to
obtain these results, in the
same way we under all forecasts
negative
we think that the c  abello was not going to come out
with this technique
and if we include results we were even
surprised because the results will be
with quite high signal intensities
except that there were some
studies that had to be evaluated
some spice that had to be
evaluated but in the end we were able to obtain as
well  a complete genetic profile with
this system
to finish, I would
also like to share with you that during the validation exercise they
had the opportunity to
test this type of cartridge in a case, that
is, in a cartridge in
this standard to salivate, not in
intel in one case  where there was an
illegal deprivation of liberty where
the corpse was cremated where there was loss
of the primary identification elements
and where they had to proceed
to carry out the
identification procedures using tissue that
could have been preserved or
through our partners we know that
those of  their procedures take us
more time in the laboratories  of
genetics and on the other hand there was a
remnant in one of the tissues that
looked like blood in the new tissue and
from there a sample was collected in my
eyes the school deposited the
fete card to what we found because
we also had an idea  that
possibly the result of the genetic profile was not going to come out
, thinking
that the event occurred at a time
after which a list was intervened,
but even so, the result
was obtained for that autopsy sample,
which we could not obtain real  from a
family member precisely on the first
attempt because we cut a
smaller amount of ft card to be
reprocessed and we were able to obtain the
genetic profile here. What is worth
mentioning and highlighting is that we were able to
do a procedure in just eight
hours processing  not only equipment 44
samples and a few bottles of repetition and
this helps a lot in the matter of
rapid identification finally and to
conclude is that we mentioned that the
te  technology that type of lost technology
'fast genetic lament without
reactively contributes to reducing
these times and this is important
especially for the technical part that
completely reduced the workflow and the
infrastructure necessary to obtain
a genetic expert and second can be
used in forensic cases where
rapid response is required
identification of people in many
states and other
countries and we know that when
these events occur it is necessary to obtain
a rapid response is a responsibility
of criminal investigation institutions
as well as all units
of genetic installation and finally
we know that this not only benefits the
technical part but also the
research procedures are
favored in this by having a quick response
thank you very much for the attention and I am
available for your questions
thank you very much
from benito thank you we have a  question do you
think they are  faeces
the genetic pepper
is cut a little but I understand that it
is necessary if the changes in the
legislation are actually to the type I think
that this issue rapid profiling
is necessary in many of the countries
and there will be states that will not have
a legislative problem when  to be able to
do it but I think that this
has to be put on the table for
discussion because it is necessary that
we, in the experience we have
had, know that a crime
an offender can fall for multiple
crimes therefore obtain these
tools intended for those
exercises for those  Those cases or those
crimes would help to solve the problems to a great extent,
but they
actually have to be placed
on the framework of the law to
ensure that in the future we can do
this type of investigation
completely and without any problem.
Ok, well, I have the issue.
We now move on with
applied
and his faith
thanks to him will give way to the word for
Manuel a
but
pe  ro thank you all are the pains and
thank you to the audience for your questions
as a final reminder because any questions
that have been submitted that our
draft has not answered today will be
addressed separately and will be posted in
the appropriate section within
jeans virtual these submissions
will be  available for
viewing until June 2021 well
in buenos aires la luz be sure to
share them with my partner who is
interested in any of the topics
covered in today's session thanks for
your participation we are opening a
technical altar ask the expert don't ask
you can also lose the
application room exhibitions and posters
are already open and feel free to
move through all the tools and
see you in kitsch 2021
thank god
thank you very much
verses